the movie starts in a military Research
Center a lieutenant is on duty
conducting a daily inspection on the
military satellites when she sees large
abnormal waves coming towards the earth
from the sun A View From Space shows us
the waves destroying every satellite on
their way the lieutenant at first does
not believe her eyes and thinks her
computer is malfunctioning she informs
the captain about the waves but is asked
to ignore any abnormality she sees for
the next 24 hours the woman finds this
suspicious and is sure that the waves
are something they should worry about
then we are introduced to Armand a scuba
diving instructor and a submarine
engineer he lives a simple life off a
coast somewhere in Turkey if that guy's
life is simple my life is dumb as hell
one morning he is approached by his
ex-girlfriend Victoria Victoria is a
marine biologist and is planning to go
on a submarine dive to the depth of the
inculic air base she has picked out a
team of five and found sponsors to fund
the trip but is in need of a submarine
and a team leader Armand refuses to join
when he finds out that the spawns sir is
his millionaire father who he hates a
day after Victoria's visit Armand gives
it a thought and decides to join the
trip to spite his father when he goes to
her place to inform her he's received by
a man Armand thinks he is in the wrong
house only to find out that the man is
Victorious fiancee Freddy he will also
join them at the air base but will stay
on the ship and handle the technical
part of the project Armand feels uneasy
working with the man but doesn't show it
on his face somewhere else the soldier
who saw the waves in the morning gets
anxious and calls her mother she asks
everyone in her family to find a safe
space underground because something
terrible is going to happen when the Sun
rises as soon as she hangs up two
soldiers barge into her house the woman
manages to trick them and drives away in
her car the scene cuts to the night of
the initiation of the submarine project
the rest of the team consists of a
foreigner Felix Armand's best friend
Benson and a college student named Rana
all five crewmates excitedly board the
ship alongside Freddy and the captain
upon reaching the air base in the middle
of the ocean Freddy and Victoria wish
each other goodbye and the crew of five
gets into the submarine the ship's
Captain stops Victoria and tells her
something strange is happening in East
Asia where the sun has risen however
they assume it won't affect them and
start The Descent everything goes well
for most of the trip and the crew stays
underwater for more than 12 hours
suddenly Armand notices that the ocean
is too bright given the fact that they
are in the aphotic zone where the
sunlight doesn't reach he moves the
submarine towards the surface declaring
that the trip is over hours later they
reach the surface but the submarine
loses connection with the ship's crew
our Mantra is shouting to get their
attention but even that doesn't work
with no options left Felix moves the
submarine towards the ship while Armand
uses a rope to climb up he and Victoria
are the first ones to get on the ship
they look everywhere only to find out
that the crew even Freddie deserted them
in the middle of the ocean in the
control room they finally find a video
of Freddy explaining what is going on in
the video he frantically tells Victoria
that the sunrise is killing people all
around the world by now almost everyone
in Asia has died and more are getting
killed every second Freddy and the crew
are going to a bunker on a nearby Island
where the sunlight cannot reach Armand
and Victoria do not waste time packing
up supplies and returning to the
submarine after the crew is informed of
what happened they make their way to the
nearest Island where the safe bunker
lies a while later they reach the shore
but as they dock the submarine they see
another giant submarine emerge just a
few meters away the group watches in awe
as a group of soldiers step out of the
submarine the captain meets Armand and
finds out about what is going on in the
world not a single person can be seen
outside so they assume everyone is in
the bunker the groups decide to join
hands to get to the bottom of the
situation suddenly Victoria's satellite
phone receives a message it is a video
of Freddy running to the bunker in the
background hundreds of people are
running around hugging their loved ones
the soldiers separate into groups and go
into the city to look for survivors
Armand Victoria and the commander also
leave to look for the bunker when they
finally reach a more populated area they
start seeing dead bodies because the
bodies have no no visible injuries
except for burnt tongues it seems as
though everyone combusted internally and
died a horrible death following the
pattern of dead bodies they reach a
church filled with more dead people who
died hugging their loved ones or praying
to God just when Victoria is about to
lose hope of seeing her fiancee a
soldier informs the commander about a
man they found in the bank it is
revealed that a man locked himself and
sought a safe in the bank and managed to
survive however his body is fried from
the inside and he doesn't have much time
to live Arman asks him where the bunker
is but only gets a vague reply at last
the commander shoots the guy dead out of
Mercy he talks to the Chief and both of
them decide to return to the submarine
in the next 30 minutes Armand and
Victoria have that much time to look for
Freddy or they will be left behind
Victoria suddenly recognizes the place
in the video Freddy sent her and drives
to the bunker with Armand back in the
bank a bunch of soldiers start pocketing
bundles of money they are stopped by the
chief engineer who enters the safe with
them suddenly the door to the safe
closes and is locked automatic
automatically a soldier named Altan
tries helping them from outside but
since no one knows the code to open the
safe they are certainly locked all 10
has to reluctantly leave his brothers to
die and return to the submarine he
starts hating Armand and his group
blaming them for his friend's death back
in the dock Rana gets a signal on her
phone and finds a news article about the
crisis it explains that the sun's
polarization changes Direction every 11
years over the course of the last few
changes the magnitude has been
decreasing gradually the most recent
change might have caused a shift and
radiated a large amount of energy enough
to kill humans and all organisms on
Earth the article has a lot of
unexplained terminology and vague
wording which Rana assumes is because
the person who wrote it must have been
in a hurry a while later Armand and
Victoria finally reached the bunker and
run inside only to find out the thick
walls did not keep the people safe many
people lie on the ground which makes
Victoria nervous she holds her breath
until she finally sees Freddy's dead
body on the ground and bursts into years
his phone lies at his side where he
recorded a final message for Victoria in
it he happily declares that he is safe
because the sun has been up for five
minutes and no one is dead yet seconds
later he starts yelling in pain and dies
dude jinxed himself as his screams echo
through the walls Armand struggles to
pause the video at last he breaks the
phone out of frustration Victoria
doesn't even have enough time to give
him a proper burial before they drive
back to the docks by the time they get
there the submarine is already closed
and ready to descend the commander
doesn't want them inside but the chief
orders him to do otherwise the group
soon realizes that the only person on
their side is the chief and the rest of
the soldiers hate them they are asked to
clean the toilets and stay away from
everyone's sight if they want to stay
safe as they are settling in the
submarine starts moving aggressively the
soldiers panic because no one knows what
the problem is moreover the chief
engineer died earlier in the bank and
the group lacks a skilled engineer
suddenly Arman recognizes the problem is
with the submarine's hide Hydraulics and
fixes them the chief impressed by his
skills makes him the chief engineer the
commander is not happy about this but he
doesn't go against the chief's decision
later the group is cleaning the living
quarters as ordered even in times of
Crisis they joke around and try to make
themselves feel better the fun time is
interrupted when Alton comes to check on
them and hits them with several insults
when the group resists he assaults
Benson having had enough Victoria goes
to the Chief and tells him about how
they are being treated like murderers
the man promises to ensure their safety
before sending them away meanwhile in
the living quarters Altan secretly
drinks alcohol with his buddies they
look for their stash of canned food and
find some missing a drunk all tan
assumes it was Victoria who stole it and
starts threatening her he is stopped by
operation officer Olivia who also
happens to be the chief's daughter Altan
doesn't stop there and wakes up every
Soldier to rebel against Armand and his
group he demands the chief throw them
out of the submarine as per the
majority's wish the chief sternly asks
him to stop causing trouble and is mad
at him for drinking when it is not
allowed moreover the soldiers are
restricted from taking canned goods to
the living quarters which gets all
tanned deeper into trouble Armand then
comes forward to apologize and calm
everyone down he explains that they need
each other to survive because they might
be the only humans alive on the planet
his wise comments make the commander
change his mind about armaan and his
group and he starts to trust them Felix
who is still in the living quarters sees
a soldier carrying a hand grenade
carelessly he panics and quickly runs to
tell everyone else about it the chief
and the rest of the group race to the
living quarters and find the man smiling
looking at the grenade the death of his
family back home has gotten the best of
him making him irrational he thinks that
everyone in the submarine should die so
they can start a new life with their
families in heaven the chief tries his
best to reason with him and calm him
down but nothing works as a last resort
he walks into the room and closes the
door behind him to save the others the
grenade goes off and both the chief and
the soldier die in the explosion seconds
later the soldiers start fixing the
Damage Done by the explosion everything
seems repairable except for a singular
hole in the floor of the control room no
matter how hard Armand tries the water
pressure doesn't let the metal stay to
cover the hole the only way to solve
this is to close it from the outside
Olivia volunteers to help our mod in the
mission even though she is still
emotionally unstable after her father's
death they swim outside and reach the
impact area Armand welds metal to cover
the hole as Olivia holds a flashlight
for a better view in the dark suddenly a
fish attacks her making her lose hold of
a necklace that was her father's last
gift she swims to get it back but loses
sight of the submarine in the process
when Armand notices her messing he goes
to look for her the two find each other
but they have trouble getting back to
the submarine again fortunately the
Electric System in the submarine is
fixed and they follow the lights to get
back inside before they reconvene with
the others Armand asks Olivia to forget
about what happened so she won't get
into trouble inside everyone is relieved
to see them safe the hole is fixed and
the water level inside the submarine
decreases the following night they reach
the army base to stock up on supplies
and find out more about what happened to
the sun Benson is assigned no tasks so
he walks up the hill to get a view of
the city upon finally reaching the top
he sees Wildfire overtaking the city
everything is happening so fast that he
can barely keep track of who he is
without his family eventually he loses
the will to live meanwhile the commander
and the others walk into the base to
find their colleagues dead in the
emergency room looking around they
realize the soldiers were trying to
think of an Escape Plan before their
death they give all the dead soldiers a
proper burial before looking around the
base for items that might come in handy
a while later as Armand and Olivia are
collecting food he realizes that
everything has lost its taste it is
almost as if the sunlight sucked out all
the nutrients from the food before they
can research further they hear a noise
and go out to check who it is somewhere
else Victoria and Benson are looking for
medicine and vitamins in the army base
Health Center Benson secretly pulls it
up hill and eats it to get high call me
crazy but this seems like a really bad
time to get high at the same time Felix
is inside the submarine with our mod
talking about his life before everything
he mentions a silver flashlight he lost
in the submarine and goes to the living
quarters to check for it suddenly he
sees a person running out of the
submarine since he and Armand were the
only ones who were supposed to be in the
quarters he follows the person soon the
soldiers join him and the episode ends
as they finally surround the stranger to
see what happens next watch the second
part in series recapped